salut à tous bienvenue d'envergure c'est
le retour avec une nouvelle fois un gros
prospects ce soir au menu puisqu'il
s'agit de jaden secondes si vous ne
connaissez pas son nom vous connaissez
peut-être la fameuse vidéo la march
madness cette année où il marque un
buzzer à la fin de la prolongation pour
donner la victoire à son équipe de
gonzaga jalan suns à un prospect qu'il
est intéressant c'est le sujet de notre
podcast du soir
[Musique]
bonsoir montréal
bonsoir paris s'est arrêté à paris welch
et paris ben avec nous pour parler des
giants tout comme alan salut les gars
est le spécialiste territoriale venue de
la data team c'est julien il va falloir
y aller
messieurs ce scouting report de janan
sexe n'attend pas en continu les gros
poissons puis ce qu'on a fait kyle
cunningham ya quelques semaines on vous
rappelle aussi que le dernier épisode
concerne justement les underdogs les
joueurs un peu moins connus vous pouvez
aller le consulter sur notre site ou sur
votre plateforme des coudes favorites
comme vous voulez et on parle de trois
joueurs dans le dernier épisode où il y
as on entend julien on entend ben
également donc allez-y c'est du miel
c'est parfait alors johnsons messieurs
je vais demander à peine évidemment
d'ouvrir le bal pour me parler de sa vie
quel homme quel homme de quel homme par
le ton avant 2 avant de parler du joueur
james êtes un jeune homme de 19 ans qui
devrait avoir de la daf
donc il est ni jeune ni vieux pour un
freshman il vient du minnesota de saint
paul au minnesota fils de larry suns et
mali malgré son père était un athlète
local accompli mais ce qui est plus
intéressant dans son background familial
c'est qu'il a deux athlètes de très haut
niveau dans sa famille le premier c'est
le secondaire de ligne de foot américain
terrell suggs qui a gagné 6 qui a gagné
le super bowl deux fois si je ne m'abuse
ou de commun avec les revenus ouais et
un autre joueur de basket très connu
trois fois all star nba et eddie jones
c'est ces deux personnages sont le
cousin sommes sont les cousins de
larissa donc ils allaient l'ascétisme
dans le sens une athlète de naissance il
a joué son basket
au lycée une académie très avec un an
très charmant qui s'appelle mis des arts
academy
oui ça fait réserve indienne un peu un
ouais un peu et je regardais je
regardais plus celui qui aime qui sont
les joueurs qui sont gratuits et demi né
à hawaï à plusieurs jeunes joueurs qui
très en vue qui sont présentement
l'académie comme rennes qui est
présentement pressenti pour être le
choix numéro 1 l'année prochaine et le
jeune terry lloyd qui est en 2024
mais le jouant dix joueurs qui sont les
seuls joueurs qui qui a fait qui peut
parler de lui c'est un dénommé béni
larrouy junior qui est graduée cette
année je crois ou l'année dernière d'un
collège de division 3 et 1 4 1 il a
shooté pour une efficacité totale de 33
% donc donc signer ce succès une c'est
une programme reconnaît exactement ce
programme chrétiens donc il vient d'une
famille pour qui c'est vraiment très
important et s'est avancé à l'année
dernière
c'est quelqu'un qui gère le grain
l'année prochain exactement c'est un
joueur qui était un peu qu'un peu été
formé pour faire ça toute sa vie
absolument ben on peut rajouter quand
même qu'il a eu un double cursus dans
l'impression il aurait existé mais pour
ceux qui le connaissent pas il sait il
pouvait devenir sans doute footballeur
américain s'il voulait il était il était
quarterbacks pour l'équipe dominée à
pour le wolf pack déminer haras et il a
été vraiment inutile une nurse jacques
roide ohio state pour devenir
quarterbacks ou quelque chose du genre
et pour ceux qui ne sont pas au courant
quant au bac c'est vraiment une des
dépositions dans le sport professionnel
qui le plus de mandats pyschologiquement
faut vraiment connaître tous et tous
avoir les jeux l'adversaire syndic est
un jeune homme quand même assez brillant
absolument nous allons passer d'ailleurs
à ses qualités de basketteur rapidement
mais mais c'était important aussi de
parler de ba2 de qui il était puisque
canton draft quelqu'un on le rappelle
pour ceux qui arriveraient pour la
première fois sur ce podcast mais on
draft aussi surtout une personne c'est
comme quand vous avez un cv les
premières lignes et bien c'est pas c'est
pas tout de suite vos qualités
professionnelles c'est d'abord où vous
êtes né quels jeux vous avez etc etc etc
pour vous situer cette année donc il
doit gonzaga et je vais vous faire un
point statistiques rapide puisque ça ne
veut pas forcément dire grand chose
surtout dans le cadre jazz angels on en
parlera plus tard mais il y tournait
quand même à une efficacité très très
bonne avec un trou shooting percentage
proche des 60 % qui était assez haut
même si gonzaga avait de toute façon des
standards assez haut mais 60% c'est très
très bien au niveau des coudes stade
brut on va dire 14 points 5 rebonds 4 5
passes pour trois ballons perdus et
quasiment deux interceptions par match
sachant qu'ils jouaient un peu moins de
30 minutes
donc quand vous mettez les stats sur
quarante minutes ça fait deux de très
très beaux chiffres
qu'est ce que je peux vous donner comme
comme stat incroyable une seule défaite
dans l'année en finale face à baylor en
finale de la march madness gonzaga qui
était invaincu toute la saison un
contexte très favorable dont va pouvoir
nous parler julien puisque toi tu as
suivi évidemment gonzaga cette saison
donc qui a tout gagné il y avait corée
qui se porte autour de lui il y avait
deux roues timmy quel était son rôle
précisément dans cette équipe julien
dans le jeu de gonzaga c1
il fait partie des deux ou trois
initiateurs du jeu avec aie aie aie nm
barde
après c'est un jeu qui est fait lécher
très très organisée donc il n'a pas un
rôle héliocentrique on va dire c'est lui
qui souvent qui porte la balle pour
amener le jeu jusqu'au terrain adverse
mais voilà tout ce qui est une situation
est assez partagée donc ça se saura
peut-être dans ses stats au niveau des
passes ou
lapin monde et reste à l'apa sont pas
éclairés et bien mais c'est pas
forcément absolument défensivement en
revanche c'était plus lui de ce que j'ai
vu moi qui défend des sur la première
option adverse à l'extérieur en tout cas
alors moi j'ai pas toujours vu ça résume
à dire ouais il est ce qu'on a vu en
défense et sa qualité de d'interception
en fait il a un gros moteur il est un
joueur quitte donc que vos collègues qui
est bonne c'est un joueur très
athlétique et il est aussi très costaud
il fut 84 13 kilos pour 1 mètre 94
il a des dames 96,15 d'envergure et
voilà gros moteur gros en défense moi je
trouve que han han un contrat il est bon
mais en même temps il a besoin de ces
biens qui a besoin de bouger pour être
bon défend je sais pas comment exprimer
si les civils restent trop statique trop
longtemps il va il va oublier son gars
il il peur de la tension quoi dans ces
cas là par contre quand il est en
mouvement
pour sa défense demandent à ce qu'il
soit en mouvement il va devenir très
intéressant
alan parle-nous de ses qualités
principales julien dans un à citer
quelques-unes dire physique mais quelle
est sa carte de visite sont entrés en
nba
même s'il en a plusieurs atouts dans sa
manche quelle caisse qui vend challenge
finalement je dirais déjà là sa vision
du jeu et son jeu de transition
c'est quelque chose qui va tout de suite
qui saute aux yeux de suite quand on le
voit le passif de deux quarterbacks
comme l'a dit
comme l'a dit ben ressorts la royauté
pour le dire aux gens c'est l'équivalent
d'un duke ou d'un kentikian ouais ouais
c'est un des cinq meilleurs vous trouvez
un des cinq meilleurs programmes c'est
vraiment très très fort donc moi je dois
la la vision du jeu en transition la
créativité à la passe qu'il arrive à
trouver
pour ses coéquipiers comprend déjà bien
ils avaient la chance comme j'ai dit
dans un système à gonzague à pike nba
rédier mais qui se rapprochait plus de
ce qui se faisait en nba que par rapport
à tous les autres programmes d'art
beaucoup de problèmes de initiés donc il
c'est un bon passeur chou un bon passeur
de driving tic en général bien un joug
du duo pick and roll contre l'écran ce
fait quand il arrive un peu lent c'est
que l'écran se fait très haut en fait
donc à neuf mètres ou des choses comme
ça il arrive souvent vraiment à faire le
bon choix là dessus donc moi je pense
que c'est vraiment là dessus on va
pouvoir bien bien figurer dans ses
premières années le scoring transition
s'il va vite je ne trouve pas hyper
explosif verticalement mais il c'est un
bon finisseur proche proche du cercle du
cercle trouve 64% à certains pour un bon
finisseur même qui il n'a pas un énorme
verticalité je trouve mais il est
intéressant là dessus on va pouvoir le
jeu de transition
le tir s'est c'est une question c'est
peut-être la chose qui peut faire un
petit peu douté sur celui ci on achète
moins le tir mais en nba il saura mener
une attaque de transition le
pick-and-roll hélas il n'a pas été tout
le temps hyper hyper fort dessus mais
les flashs sont là et là il a quand même
montré une belle variété de passer de
type de lecture sur pick'n roll bien
plus que d'autres meneurs de son âge
et puis à l'aspect défensif aussi on
achète aussi un joueur qui devraient pas
être pénalisants pour son équipe
pas du tout alors peut-être peut-être sa
première année c'est très dur d'être
pénalisant sa saison rookie mai mais il
devrait être assez vite efficace 27 des
choses à ajouter sur les forces évidente
candidat alain son athlétisme s'exprime
pas vraiment de manière verticale mais
horizontale sa joie qui est très très
rapide
comme je vous disais dans le chatt aval
avant l'épisode et je suis pas le gars
qui est le plus excité sur les premiers
pas mais le premier pas de dire une
seule chose d'absolument incroyable
il est vraiment très dur à battre lorsqu
il va au panier pour moi vraiment cette
qualité de finisseur est tellement
supérieur pour les jeunes de son âge qui
sait à peu près l'équivalent d'une
qualité de 2 c après l'équivalent d'un
bon shoot pour moi ça va ouvrir
absolument tout le reste de son jeu il
est capable de finir rapidement sur à
peu près tout le monde dans les petits
petits espaces donc lorsqu'il va se
mettre à passer alors il ya souvent
cette critique julien cette critique
semi critique / / gonzaga en disant
qu'ils affrontent pas des grosses
équipes il ya quand même de bons
défenseurs dans sa conférence qui ont
défendu sur lui sur james hayes
oui et puis les matchs ont pas toujours
été facile mais cela le bilan global est
excellent il écrase en l'écrasant mais
savoir qu'il ya qui a montré beaucoup de
disciplines quoi beaucoup d'adaptations
et beaucoup de discipline pour intégrer
dans leurs le système de gonzaga je
pense que je vais y penser et il y avait
là dedans il a réussi à non seulement
montré ses qualités pour bien parler
physique de chimie sion au cercle de
prise de risque et puis en même temps de
s'adapter à ce jeu qui doit comme disait
ben il faut apprendre beaucoup de
systèmes parce qu'ils sont ajoutés les
schémas way absolument absolument et
c'est intéressant parce que là on peut
renvoyer d'ailleurs à la longue
interview et qui était franchement bien
qu'à donner joël à yayi au au podcast
basket de rmc et dans laquelle joue à la
ja y parle de giant size et il dit ils
savaient très bien signant ici qu'il
n'allait pas avoir tous les ballons ils
savaient très bien que il serait une
option parmi d'autres et c'est ce qui a
fait que ça a fonctionné ça n'aurait pas
fonctionné avec n'importe qui donc ça
c'est ça c'est un truc qu'on peut
mentionner alex pense tu as raison c'est
le choix du c'est un choix de carrière
mais qu'il va devenir de plus en plus
populaire exactement c'est il aurait pu
aller dans un programme
là où vont 2,3 freshman on les connaît
sur deux programmes et avoir plus de
ballons et pouvoir montrer plus son
talent mais il a choisi gonzague a en
fait il a choisi parce qu'il s'est dit
ça s'adapte à mon jeu et moi je trouve
que c'est un choix hyper mature de sa
part et et qui en fait le montre déjà
qu'il est insérables dans ce collectif
alors que souvent on a ce tête des fois
cette question sur pas mal de gros
freshman en fait oui c'est ça il n'ya
pas c'est ce qui le démarque en fait
deux c'est assez simple il ya il le peut
être que le talent intrinsèque n'est pas
forcément plus hauts que ceux qui vont
être choisis entre 5 et 15 mai c'est ce
qui le démarque clairement c'est la
maturité et le fait que l'on prend
quasiment pas de risques aujourd'hui
quand on choisit jones ben ce qui nous
amène à la psychologie de l'animal ouais
puisque tu aimes bien décortiquer les
interviews les interactions ce qui se
passe sur le terrain comment tu juges la
manière de d'être de gênes sexe très
mature très éduquée à qu'est ce que
c'est un peu je demande de de jouer dans
une équipe cela concerne que beaucoup
d'athlètes de haut niveau qui ont
expliqué qu est-ce que qu'est ce que ça
veut dire
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ces
sacrifices qui sont qui sont nécessaires
pour réussir ce billet je vous disais
quand on le le cousin de ton passé et
dit john je pense que quelques trucs à
apprendre
si ton rêve dans la vie c'est de jouer
en nba il était très mature et ça ça se
monte dans son jeu aussi
il va justement il je pense pour moi il
est allé à illustrer qui était pas
chamakh rocard mais tel un jeu de passes
a aussi aussi la sombre notre match
heures c'est ce qui est intéressant
aussi c'est de le background un peu
chrétien c'est très laid de famille
proche c'est un macbook est très
conservateur donc on veut je crois pas
qu'on parle non plus d'un jeune homme
qui allait faire la fête dans les clubs
et se perdre dans la nuit d'atlanta
les hawks mais c'est vrai que c'est vrai
que c'est important à souligner comment
il réagit dans l'adversité puisque
gonzaga tout gagné comment il réagit
dans la
la difficulté la défaite bah moi j'ai
beaucoup aimé que ce soit lui en charge
j'ai beaucoup aimé que ce soit lui en
charge d'y donner je contribue aussi à
l'est dans la demi finale je pense que
ça a montré une un désir certains de
prendre de prendre la de prendre charge
dans le fond du destin de son équipe ce
qui est vraiment pour un malheur qui
auront quelque chose de très important
sinon je l' ai vu je n'ai vu parler
après quelques après des défaites aux
eaux au lycée ce que je trouvais
intéressant c'est qu'il est pas
nécessairement a battu c'est le genre de
personne pour qui c'est important de
jouer le meilleur match qui peut jouer
de jouer le jouer au basket de la bonne
manière et si il joue parce que la
meilleure manière possible pour lui ce
qui qui gagne qui perd ses pots c'est
pas la fin du monde il y aura toujours
un match suivant julien que disent je
sais pas si tu as pu avoir des déclas de
nouveau juste en voyant les matchs que
disent ses coéquipiers de lui
et que dit son attitude pendant le match
aussi ben on a déjà un peu parlé dont
les mac c'est et c'est quelqu'un qui
vous dire très intégré ça se sent
l'attitude clients entre entre lui et
les tauliers de l'équipe qui sont là
depuis deux trois ans avec la passe très
très bien
il est bon sens qu'il est bien intégré
il y avait des interviews avant la
saison où il est notamment corée qui
espère parler de ce petit jeu entre eux
pour savoir qui était le meilleur dans
différents raconte dans différentes
disciplines tout ça et puis jusqu'à la
fin cédé il ya une vraie solidarité et
de toute façon ils n'ont pas perdu à
part un match et on sentait que même
quand c'était comment dire 56 soit + 10
plus 15 au milieu de deuxième mi temps
il réagit comme les autres c'est-à-dire
que si printanier qui trouve ça bête ils
sont des fascistes quoi comme tous les
autres il y avait donc il était vraiment
intégré dans la dans la culture gonzaga
assez vite et je pense que les dernières
images ont parlé des demi finales les
dernières images de la finale
quand il et on a l'impression qu'il va
vers le tout le monde c'est coacher ses
coéquipiers en s'excusant et pape sy a
gagné donc il ya il avait envie d'être
là ce jour là sa part c'est en tant
qu'équipe
peut-être qu'il est aussi pour quelque
chose mais c'était assez touchants pour
lui et ses coéquipiers de la façon dont
ils ont aussi encaissé la défaite
vraie attitude de leader absolument bon
vous brosse un portrait nu team usa
aussi alex chez les jeunes oui oui il a
perdu j'ai vu un peu perdu non il n'a
jamais perdu mais on l'a vu en terme de
mentalité moi je le trouvais génial avec
team usa chez les jeunes toujours
encouragé ses potes alors qu'il n'avait
pas du tout la tête d'affiché team usa
il était un spotter shooter mais super
dans l'attitude et puis déjà il ya déjà
joué avec des top top joueur il savait
se fondre dans le collectif ça ça remet
un peu sur ce qu'on disait mais il n'ya
pas que le contexte gonzague a aussi où
le contexte miné à il ya le contexte il
me said et triple médaillé aux et triple
médaillé que la multi donc absolument
alan tu gardes le crachoir puisque il
faut quand même mettre un petit peu d
des ratures sur ce beau portrait
convient de dresser
ouais en fait wes johnson
je pense qu'on est souvent on attend
souvent trop d des joueurs qu'on utilise
par top 5 on veut tout soumettre des all
stars mais chaque prospect à des
difficultés et déjà si tu tires un
joueur qui signe deux contrats chez toi
et tu es titulaire c'est déjà bien
moi je pense que j'ai du mal peut-être à
le voir voilà est un des initiateurs
principal d'attac en nba alors si on
drague top 5 des peut-être l'équipe qui
va les fans de cette équipe qui vont le
le prendre vont se dire bon là on aura
un meneur all star c'est est ce qu'ils
vont se dire toi mais je suis je suis
pas persuadé que c'est par l'initiation
d'attac par delà du beaucoup de jeux de
pick and roll du shoot en sortie
terrible
elle arrivera sert raison pour quelle
raison de son jeu tu peux dire ça je
sais pas si j'achète le tir en fait tout
simplement je sais pas si j'achète le
tir et je je je trouve que il ya il ya
ben parler d'un fort premier pas je suis
d'accord mais c'est pas là l'athlète
devra après avoir revu par un nuage
s'est pas l'athlète explosif qu'on
entend peu partout jeu on lit nous on ne
dit pas mais quand je lis du jo ann woll
du russell westbrook c'est pas du tout
ça
chase je trouve que le procès ça c'est
plus jane green si on veut trouver en
termes de premier pas et d'explosivité
je trouve que c'est un jour qui quittent
eux battent plus sur une situation et
que sa tête qu'avec son corps et donc ça
peut limiter en top niveau nba et le
shoot en sortie de dribble
j'ai vu pas mal de tirât
pas exceptionnel la mécanique que la
mécanique et pas mal je trouve qu aux
lancers francs c'est un peu décevant
pendant un an mais bon ça se travaille
un lancer franc voit c'est juste mac
c'est juste ma crainte sur lui ce qui
fait qu'il ne deviendrait pas peut-être
ce sumner en 24 ans 24 8 que toutes les
franchises peut-être le veulent drafté
en l'ayant je pense que c'est moi je
pense que ça peut être plus un troisième
ou quatrième joueur du nomes une
excellente équipe
moi je parle beaucoup de modèles jour où
l idée c'est peut-être il me fait
beaucoup penser à lui plus casse tous
ces meneurs là parce qu'il trouvait que
quelques limitations dans son jeu encore
physique et un tir que je suis pas
encore persuadé que ce sera une arme
létale en plus donc le 75 % aux lancers
francs 40 3% sur l'île ont deux points
messieurs n'a pas pris beaucoup ce qui
ce qui est plutôt bien et notamment
seulement 22 seulement 10% des longs
deux points étaient venait d'une passe
décisive et seulement 1 3 point sur deux
ce qui peut expliquer alors que à trois
points il est à whale à 34 % ce qui est
énorme mais ce qui peut s'expliquer
aussi du fait qu'ils prenaient pas le de
poules la moitié la moitié donc toi si
je suis le raisonnement tu peux hésiter
cité une franchise qui recherchent le
for hope side tu peux hésiter avec pas
mal d'autres freshman qui semble avoir
un plafond plus haut parce qu'on parle
on parle pour parler très clairement une
amie kate dans une catégorie au dessus
on parle de jane green qui a un plus
fort premiers pas peut-être un plus fort
potentiel on parle des vannes moblie
mais il ya aussi ceux qui sont derrière
il ya les coming à l'est boston les
williams
est ce que toi tu le tu hésites du coup
si tu as le choix 5 admettons qu'il est
là et qui à zéro il ya le prendre non je
pense quoi je pense que je le prends
parce qu'en fait je pense qu'il est
encore au plancher ça qu'il faut dire
aussi je pense pas que john ce sera un
mauvais joueur nba jeu sa capacité à
j'aime pas le mot buzz t1 mais sa
capacité à ne pas avoir de deuxième
contrat ou est un simple genre de
rotation sur le deuxième contrat je la
trouve moins importantes que d'autres
tout en ayant un potentiel qui n'est pas
si loin des potentiels qu'on peut qu'on
peut on peut projeter sur les scotty
barnes d ailleurs williams ou des kim
johnsson comme tu l'as dit je me rends
compte avec jane green pour moi il n'y a
pas d'hésitation je pense que je suis
proche du pré en jane green avant avant
des red sox
parce que je pense que jen une
offensivement va vraiment on en
reparlera mais excellé en nba le débat
avec mobley il est intéressant sur aussi
la position ce que qu'est-ce qu'on
qu'est-ce qu'on mais qu'est ce qu'on met
en avant il à répondre vraiment le verbe
pour vale to value en français qu'est ce
qu'on attend d'un accord de la valeur et
que ming a qu'une glace est une énigme
un peu pour moi je dirais que c'est en
train de beaux de boma on en parlera
plus tard mais ben
on parlait de ses limites donc alan à
mettez un point d'interrogation sur le
le zeit du shoot on va dire sur la
capacité d'être un shooter plus
performant même s'il est déjà un shooter
correct à devenir un très bon shooteur
en gros ça que tu voulais dire elle il
ya certaines personnes qui trouvent au
cycle wendel est très maigre et moi j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya des petites mains
alors j'aimerais bien savoir
mais j'ai vraiment j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya des petites mains et que du
coup c'est le salon handicap mais mais
c'est moins facile d'avoir un bon
haendel quand tu as des petites mains
quoi donc qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
t'en pense d'eux est ce que en fait les
défauts qu'on lui trouve son améliorable
ou est ce qu'il ya vraiment des défauts
structurels
bon il est petite moins c'est un bon
point je sais pas exactement mais ça
explique un peu loose des fois comme on
dit qui est un peu les critères pelous
moi j'aime je trouve qu'il manque un peu
de créativité des fois un mythe eric je
trouve que en transition il est
absolument incroyable il voit tout le
monde un peu partout tandis qu'albi
terrain appliquée drôle comme disait
plutôt des fois ça vaut un petit peu
dans le tunnel
ils voient ils se ramassent des fois il
s'est ramassé beaucoup avec des prises à
deux reprises à 3 puis sans
nécessairement passer mais ça s'améliore
soit cette vision là va s'améliorer avec
beaucoup de jeu et beaucoup de
répétitions côté un billet que je crois
qu'il va avoir parce que défensivement
parlant est capable de rester sur le
terrain c'est pour ça que dans le fond
moi aussi j'aime beaucoup la comparaison
à jour c'est pas un initiateur en
primaire mais presque
je crois que c'est un peu le destin qui
l'a pas une bille comme comme ça à lanus
yssingeaux avec un trait au plancher
julien quel type de joueur il sera en
nba ce que tu penses qu'il qui a
heureusement pas faire madame irma mais
ce qui peut avoir le même rôle à peu
près kaguya gars c'est à dire ben je
manque la balle parfois c'est moi qui
nie sil attaque et parfois c'est pas moi
est ce que tu penses que ça peut c'est
quelque chose aussi qui peut lui
convenir quoi
oui il sert il ya en tout cas au début
il va avoir besoin de d'un autre world
pour voilà pour soi tout à côté de vie
comme alan parce que l'instant il n'a
pas insulté l'île soit être quelqu'un de
plus créateur quoi pour sûr après il a
quand même il ya quand même un jeu assez
exceptionnelles de relance et par
rapport à ce que tu fais là l'un pour
campari vent ya peut être une force un
meneur avec un beau un cerveau bien fait
qui est très fort à la relance fiscale
après un jeu même dans le creux aux
excès il a dit perd presque trois
ballons par match qui est énorme
le ratio à passes décisives tendu à
l'idée n'est pas très très bon il est
pas élite mais il est correct je lai à
part dont 1,5
c'est vrai que c'est pas énorme mais
effectivement il ya aussi une partie dû
à son rôle
ils n'avaient pas forcément les passes
décisives les plus faciles c'est à dire
enfin de système un peu classique où tu
vas tu vas décalé de route imi qui en
plus ajouté à 75% à gonzaga mais par
contre les ballons difficiles c'était
pour lui donc effectivement il pouvait
en perdre mais c'est vrai que on note
des limitations pour le moment sur le
under et le tir moi je suis plus
optimiste sur le tir que sur le
que sur le under cette histoire demain
qui me trotte dans la tête mais il ya
toujours l'état d'esprit comme vous
disiez tout ce qui est très important
qui peut nous donner des garanties sur
sur l'avenir quelles valeurs ça amène un
joueur comme giants en nba pour une
équipe à sa juste valeur qui est
absolument avoir beaucoup de flexibilité
dans ce qu'on fait avec un joueur du
périmètre qui est capable de faire
autant de choses même s'il ne fait pas
un truc vraiment de manière élite élite
magri que je crois que ça sa finition
rester telle est en nba on peut l'on
peut le faire je posterai on peut faire
jouer passer d'eux on peut faire jouer
nos postes de loi post 3 donc en
playoffs c'est intéressant je prends
d'avoir un joueur comme ça on arrive
mais surtout un joueur qui est capable
de produire comme john sykes pitié pas
non plus un croc qui est capable de cava
de passer le ballon qui est capable de
se mettre l'équipe devant lui je crois
qu'il ya une énorme
alan jeu quel contexte je ne monte pas
un contexte d' équipe parce que ça peut
changer avec la free agency et c'est
dans quel contexte il serait bon de le
voir évoluer dans les premières années
si je prends un exemple pour les
auditeurs théo maledon était en contexte
idéal cette année à ok si parce qu'il a
pu s'habituer à un nouveau système il
avait du temps de jeu etc
il ya d'autres joueurs qui auront plus
besoin d'être dans des équipes
compétitives
je pense à un air djebar est par exemple
qui est plus l'équipe est compétitive
meilleur il est voilà c'est ce genre de
personnage quel est le meilleur contexte
pour qu'à la fois il progresse
ouais pour qu'ils progressent pour
qu'ils se développent pour qu'il
devienne le meilleur le meilleur lui
même
moi je dirais le un peu bien le contexte
que la mélo ont fait à charlotte des
infor coire d'un côté et un partenaire
de pick and roll
en fait de route 6000 c'était un super
partenaire de pick and roll mais il n'y
avait pas le pick n pop avait une route
chimie pas assez je pense que vraiment
ça peut vraiment pas mal d'avoir ce
genre de genre en nba beaucoup
d'équipement se joueront ces intérieurs
là je pense que il lui faudrait je pense
comme l'a dit ben c'est un élévateur de
plancher et c'est un joueur de type
play-offs donc de facto cd dans une
bonne équipe il va vraiment ressortir
il ya avait travers des bons joueurs je
compare pas halliburton ans par exemple
mais halliburton on savait très bien que
si tu es dans une bonne équipe ils
allaient faire une solide saison une
solide saison rookie et que le conseil
était peut-être pas immense là je dirais
que c'est même chose pour se grimer
qu'il ya quand même un peu plus
d'obstacles donc je pense qu'une une
forte équipe en fait une équipe qui va
peut-être s'est retrouvé un peu de
chance à la loterie l'équipe tient car
un fort joueur sur les bases extérieur
et un intérieur capable de scorer sur de
plusieurs manières
je pense que ça peut être bien je pense
que il est c'est pas le genre de joueur
qui va avoir un compte qui nécessite le
contexte d'un kane donc qui arrive et on
réorganise un petit peu toutes les
planètes autour de lui puisque le livre
est rincé rab dans pas mal de jeux et
c'est pour ça peut-être que pas mal
d'équipés peuvent être intéressés en
fait parce que comme il ya des équipes
qui veulent trois meneurs maintenant une
biais il ya beaucoup de deux choses
versatile qui se font sur les
utilisations de line up et hamadi ben il
est assez rare dans pas mal de trucs
donc je pense que lui parle des parcours
pour aller répondre je vois il répété je
pense qu'ils gagneraient à être dans une
lettre avec un fort pour un beau un vrai
bon joueur sur le bas courte je pense
que comme je roule idée quand il ya un
gros genre sur le bas-côté avec mais ça
se passe très bien
j'ai fait la comparaison sur le fameux
site barque torts vick qui nous
proposent des stats avancées et des
comparaisons de stats a lancé les
premières comparaisons qui tombe au
niveau des freshman puisque dans les
saisons sophomore on a dû alexander
walker et dodson 70 à 100
just e-swin slow joe hallyday stanley
johnson john holmes voilà les cinq les
quatre premiers noms ou retombent en
termes de comparaison de stade avancé
ça veut rien dire évidemment met donc
son profil c'est un bon pourcentage
d'assists un bon pourcentage
d'interception un pourcentage de pro un
fouillis trade donc le la fréquence de
fautes subies et deux sur la aller sur
la lune la fréquence à des souris mâles
l'afrique mouais mais si j'arrive pas à
trouver le verbe qui vomit peu importe
la fréquence de lancers-francs quoi par
rapport au nombre de tirs général est
relativement élevé sans être
exceptionnel et l'avantagent qu'il a
surtout tous les autres de la cuvée
c'est qu'il a vraiment un pourcentage à
2 points excellence qui s'explique aussi
par par gonzaga
et qui d'autre avait un pourcentage est
excellent mais allait beaucoup plus sur
la ligne des lancers francs c'était
james harden qui est beaucoup plus bas
dans la liste des comparaisons mais
qu'elle a quand même
voilà donc est-ce que vous avez quelque
chose à ajouter est ce que l'un de vous
a une réserve à quelque chose de noter
sur un papier qu'il aimerait absolument
dire sur johnson
j'ai vidé mon sac ça faisait longtemps
qu'ils étaient pleins et des vides et
julien ont tout est ok tout est ok jalan
sexe donc emballé c'est pesé
vous l'aurez compris une valeur sûre la
question pour les frontoffice ça va être
de savoir à quel point ils vont accorder
de l'importance à c'était cette espèce
de vague de confiance qu'on peut avoir
en son plancher le fait qu'ils se
développent puisque ça a l'air d'être
quelqu'un de facile entre guillemets à
développer donc c'est évidemment
évidemment quelque chose de très
important et qui lui donnera de la cote
pour pour sa draft dès 2021 puisque
évidemment il est candidat
messieurs merci
je vous retrouve des biens très bientôt
sur le site envergure penser aux
puisqu'on va sortir une grosse batterie
de scouting report
à court terme
pour cette grave 2021 et puis évidemment
vous pouvez réécouter nos anciens
podcast ya un article aussi de dahlan et
ma nuque et à la une sur le gâteau il y
a le podcast underdogs auquel julien et
ben ont participé donc il ya tout plein
de choses tout plein de contenus sur
envergure abonnez vous sur twitter sur
un site à aller voir notre site et
mettez nous des bonnes notes sur les
applis des coudes si vous nous écoutez
sur apple music sur google podcasts ou
autres sur stitcher et je veux que
sais-je
il a plein merci messieurs on se
retrouve très bientôt et puis on vous
fait des bisous prenez soin de vous ciao